I really love lost
stories so I'm from this very tiny hot
island in the middle of the Caribbean
called Nassau hases anyone here ever
heard of
it
yeah I distinctly remember the place
being so small that I could land there
shout from the airport
my brothers would somehow hear me and
they would know to come and pick me up
the North Pole however is an
inhospitable frozen tundra that's
incredibly difficult to get to not to
surprise any of you but I am the first
behemon presumably to set foot at the
North
Pole it's
true now if you would to speak to my
parents about what I was like growing up
they would tell you that I was
mischievous
precocious the kid devouring all the
information and never ever taking a no
for an answer but if you got them into a
secret room they would also tell you
that I was a pain in the butt and a
troublemaker early in my practice it was
important for me to create an artwork
that would share the sense of vastness
that I had experienced in the Arctic
with my community so on a second
Expedition I decided to move this 4.5
ton piece of ice from frozen Arctic
River and bring that to my
neighborhood I'd work with a team of
scientists and engineers and together we
would install this block of ice in a
solar powered friezer unit outside of my
childhood
classroom on this 100 degree
date now the response was a mix of
excitement and wonder the folks in my
neighborhood had never really seen ice
quite like this it was my way of telling
the story of our deep connections to
each other now while all of this was
going on I realized I was having a
separate journey of Discovery it was on
this Expedition where I began to hear
Whispers of an unknown polar Explorer
named Matthew Henson now up until this
point the fact that the first person to
set foot in the north pole looked like
me hide me a gas I mean come on look at
this
guy
in 1909 Hensen and fellow Explorer
Robert Perry had done what no others had
done up to that point they had made it
to the North Pole now this son of a
share CER managed over seven Arctic
Expeditions yet his massive massive
contributions became lost to
history and I ain't really cool with
that so since this lightning bolt moment
my work became a quest to tell tell
these lost
stories and to tell all of you the truth
if you really pay attention you start to
see these lost stories all around you
and when you find them you realize that
they can speak with a very loud
mouth now growing up my grandparents
house was the place where my entire
beham and family would me every Sunday
for Sunday dinner now I got a big family
so 13 aunts and uncles and 52 cousins
would all squeeze into my grandparents
tiny
home and for sure the house was small
but it was a sanctuary filled with life
and
love now I believe I was around 12 years
old when my grandfather came home with
the first set of
encyclopedias in our community this was
a big
deal my uncles who were some big dudes
would never let us get close to these
books without wearing gloves guys can
you all believe
that I couldn't wait for my turn to Fan
through these pages and as I would fan
through these
Pages the questions would arrest me like
who wrote all of this and how did they
write all of it and was everything in
the entire universe arrested in these
pages and as I would find through
this book further a question really hit
me no one from my community was in these
pages and if they were missing then what
else was
lost so years
later with infinite more
questions I decided to make my own
encyclopedia it's called the
Encyclopedia of in
visibility this is
a 3,000
page leatherbound book that has over
177,000
entries and yes it was difficult but I
read every single last one of them now
the first entry that I wrote was on you
guys may have guessed it the Explorer of
Matthew Hensen the one that I learned
about my first Arctic Expedition
from there I thought who and what else
should be included in these pages I
would make list after list of things
that were excluded from history and
researched them at first it was just me
alone then I needed an assistant and
then I needed an entire team and
together we would comb the globe looking
for people places and things that were
mostly
Untold now this is arranged
alphabetically and the organizing
principle was to try to include the
kinds of things that you may not ever
learn at school so let look at this
entry on the Mino there a powerful all
female military regimen from the kingdom
of the homie which is current de Bine
then there's an entry on Robert Smalls
now the great Robert Smalls freed
himself from slavery overtook a bunch of
Confederate ships freed a whole bunch of
slaves from those ships and then
majestically marched on to become one of
the first black Cong in the United
States then there's an entry on
rhinoceros did any of you know there was
a woly rhinoceros
no then there's an entry on sister
Rosetta Tharp sister Rosetta Tharp is
the mother of all rock and roll then
there's an entry on be movies now who
can't handle a high quality be movie
then there's an entry on the great John
Edmundston the man that taught a very
young Charles Darwin the art of
Taxidermy and a whole lot more to come
to think of it the only entry missing
from this book is an entry that explains
how you can put a full pair of socks
into a dryer and
somehow only one foot comes
out now after 12 years a limited edition
of this encyclopedia was published as an
artwork occupying these territories
between sculpture book and installation
and this experience truly convinced me
that there are an infinite amount of law
stories to be told and there's no real
limits to how they can be told so in
2014 I decided to creade an artwork in
honor of astronaut Robert Henry Lawrence
now Robert Lawrence was the first black
astronaut he never realized his dream of
space as he was killed in a flight
accident in 1967 at the age of 32 now my
goal was to honor Robert and to bring
his profound Legacy
to
space now those of you who know anything
about space you would know that that's
easier said than done because after all
they ain't a bunch of Island folks
walking around with rockets in their
back pockets so step one was to find
someone with a
rocket and who has Rockets the head of
SpaceX quen
shawell and then I had to figure out who
was going to be as interested in these
law stories as I
was the head of SpaceX Gwen
shawell we were introduced by the LA
County Museum and after four years of
rigorous testing planning and sculpting
a satellite was produced in honor of
Robert now this satellite was made of
gold and it was important for me to have
this satellite follow an ancient
Egyptian tradition of Storytelling by
imbuing the essence of a person into a
container now this satellite was called
Enoch after the story of a mythological
character whose walk with the gods was
so close that he never ever died on
November 30th
2018 Enoch blasted into space in the
belly of a SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket into
orbit almost 50 years after his
passing the legacy of Robert Henry
Lawrence is celebrated amongst the
Stars
now I've spent my entire life being
obsessed with these law
stories can these lost stories hold a
key that unlocks our sense of
belonging lost stories definitely need
to be told not in small ways but in ways
that match the Ambitions of the people
that we speak for now I know all of you
have access to Lost stories so please
let's not let them be lost forever even
if that means
you're called a pain in the butt or
troublemaker and thank
you